[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing a supporting character
and a spine chilling moment in the
half-blood prince where she's the victim
of a brutal curse
katie bell was a british half-blood
witch born in the year 1979
she was a member of gryffindor house and
represented the house on the quidditch
pitch
taking on the role of chaser she was a
year above harry
and we see her name mentioned here and
there throughout the franchise
however her character was never really
brought to the forefront of our minds
until the half-blood prince when while
on a trip to hogsmeade
katie suffered a brutal attack from an
unidentified curse something that the
trio
witnessed firsthand at once katie rose
into the air
gracefully her arms outstretched as
though she was about to fly
yet there was something wrong something
eerie her hair
whipped her by the fierce wind but her
eyes were closed and her face was quite
empty of expression
then six feet above the ground katie let
out a terrible scream
her eyes flew open but whatever she
could see
or whatever she was feeling was clearly
causing her terrible anguish
it was a truly bone chilling sinister
moment that encapsulated the reality of
dark magic
and it was a great example of the dark
undertone that the books and films began
to develop
as they progressed katie's body was
dragged and thrown around violently by
what appeared to be some sort of
invisible entity and the trio could only
look on in terror
as katie's body was viciously thrown to
the ground hagrid shows up just in the
nick of time
to bring katie's unconscious body to
saint mangos and it's there that people
begin to discuss
what exactly happened to katie upon
closer inspection
it quickly became clear that katie was
holding a cursed object
the opal necklace now if you read the
books you probably have a slightly
better understanding of the opal
necklace and what it is
the films didn't really touch on it much
but there's actually some foreshadowing
in the chamber of secrets
when harry mistakenly enters borgen and
berks in 1992
he sees the necklace on display with a
warning label
do not touch cursed has claimed the
lives of 19 muggle owners to date
so what exactly happened to katie why
did she have a cursed necklace in the
first place
while on her trip to hogsmeade katie was
actually placed under the imperious
curse by the three broomstick's
innkeeper
madame resmerta who was under the
imperius curse herself
a curse administered by none other than
draco malfoy
the film doesn't explain this
particularly well it certainly suggests
that malfoy is responsible
but doesn't divulge the minutia of the
situation katie was instructed to take
the cursed opal necklace
which she finds inside the girl's
bathroom to dumbledore
it was an assassination attempt the only
reason that katie fell victim to the
curse
was because she argued with her friend
leanne about the package
this led to the package ripping and
katie coming into direct contact with
the cursed object
the necklace possesses a very deadly
curse but you can only fall victim to
its effects when you touch it directly
it appears that the more contact that is
made the more of an effect that it will
have
katie merely touched it through a small
hole in her glove and it took her six
months to recover
in saint mungo's it was a truly violent
scene and i can't even begin to imagine
what it would have done to dumbledore
had he himself opened the package and
touched it fully
it's untelling what curse the opal
necklace actually possesses
but what immediately stuck out to me is
the way that the cursed necklace
resembles the horcrux horcruxes are
objects in which a dark witch or wizard
has imbued part of their soul the
purpose of which is to make it difficult
for them to be completely killed
however one of the most common
properties of a horcrux is that it
contains some sort of
defense mechanism a counter-charm curse
or
jinx we see this with voldemort tall
cruxes and
given the power of the opal necklace i
think that there's a case to be made
for the opal necklace being a horcrux
itself it wouldn't be one of voldemort's
horcruxes
we know that but i do have a theory for
who it could belong to
if it is in fact a horcrux if you guys
want me to make a video exploring that
further
let me know down in the comment section
below that's it for this video
until next time you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you